so when did you start your company 2010
so was that I'm just trying to figure
out the table line yeah so O3 so o1 I go
to university okay O3 is my first Summer
Okay and then I sell an
03040506 and then I do my graduating
year I sell an 07 and then I do one more
year because in 07 I sold that summer I
made like 130 000 uh that summer so I
saved up like quite a lot of money for a
university student coming out of school
and then I travel for a year and then in
2008 I go I sell books again and then uh
I travel again for a year and a half and
then I come back and start a company so
I got a lot of traveling done like
before I kind of took on this this you
know undertaken and what inspired you to
start your company
um what like what was that was there an
aha moment yes like what okay one thing
I didn't mention is in 2008
I left the book thing before I went to
travel I took a corporate consulting job
in Texas
lived in Dallas and uh
that lasted three months
I gotta go because same thing I was just
super ambitious and like like just
having all these ideas
I I relate to that so much yeah they
hated me in corporate they hated me well
corporate people are not like you know
anybody with an MBA just hates me
because I I don't think like them at all
like I'm not linear I want to explore I
want to take risks you know I read a
statistic today that an average
millionaire files bankruptcy 3.5 times
in their life that's insane really yeah
that's insane I was shocked when I read
that but I looked at the data like oh my
God there's tasks to back that up which
means that millionaires are people that
will take risks and fail and try again
until they succeed so that's a
resiliency argument actually it's not a
failure argument it's a resiliency
argument right and so
um corporate people they're not into
failure like they just want the safest
thing for everything and I'm going in
there let's try this let's try that and
they're like you're insane and so three
months in I'm like I can't do this so I
left
and I was just thinking like I I
probably should start a business because
um I don't think I'm employable like I
just realized I don't think I'm
employable
at first I had that same thought like
literally when I was in corporate
because I would always go to my
management and just ask them like can we
use this software like why are we doing
it this way this doesn't make any sense
and like I'm 24 22. I don't know 22 to
24 I think I was so like what is this
chick talking about she doesn't know
anything yeah plus I hate stupid rules
thank you
stupid rules yeah yeah stupid rules it's
okay so they let you go why why suits so
I made a list of things uh again I
wanted to be strategic uh there was an
incident in my life that I refer a lot
to new people we hire in our company
which is I had a mentor I talked about
the show yesterday he had sold this
company for about 50 million dollars at
39 years old and then he started at a
non-profit he put me on the board of
that nonprofit
just so I can learn he said I just want
you to learn it was a wonderful thing he
did so it was a Sunday I'm in his office
on a Sunday and we're raising money to
build a new facility at UBC to build a
new building at UBC that was the
fundraiser he undertook for his
organization
non-profit and uh this guy walks in this
little chubby uh white curly hair with a
hat guy looks about 60. walks in he's
you know shakes hands and gives him an
envelope well see and walks away
and so
this matter of mine
um
ayal he opens the envelope and there's a
half a check for half a million dollars
from him to you from no not from him to
you from this from to me to from this
old man to you all that was a donation
he gave half a million dollars to help
fund this building that I always
building wow half a million dollars okay
so I'm I don't know I mean I had money
at the time but not like half a million
dollars to donate money you know because
I'm like 24 and I'm looking at like uh
what I've never seen a half a million
dollar check before it's incredible
experience actually to be in that energy
you know and I go that guy just gave you
half a million dollars he's like yeah he
donates half a million dollars to US
every year
I go you see the biggest donor he's like
no there are people who do a million
dollars a year for us keep in mind we're
building a you know transparently like
uh growing up Jewish in the Soviet Union
this this was building a a a campus uh
you know building for the uh Halal
foundation so like the Jewish student
Community which I'm sure is going to get
a lot of hate online because all these
conspiracies no there's no conspiracy I
grew up poor
um but that Community does have a ton of
money like it's a very you know wealthy
community and these are and these are
very successful people but this is the
most unassuming little old man that
walked in gave a check for half a
million dollars you know
and I go hey y'all like
what do you have to do with your life
to be able to give away a half a million
dollars for just something you believe
in
y'all like thought about he goes you
know
all of these guys do something different
like Neil was the guy's name to give the
money happens to be in construction his
friends Jonathan's an accountant he
gives like a million dollars
he went through all these names he's
like they all do different the one guy
is an orthopedic surgeon everybody does
something different he goes but there's
one thing they all have in common and
this is profound to hear this at 24 he
goes the one thing the Olive in common
is they've all ever only done one thing
what does that mean he goes they've all
been married to the same woman since
I've known them for the last 30 plus
years and they've all only had one job
mind blown you know that was that was
prophetic because
like you know you go now to 2023 and
people jump from relationship to
relationship jump from job to job it's
too hard and doesn't work doesn't matter
like this they don't people don't
understand or value commitment and value
resiliency people value oh I'll get a
200 raise if I switch jobs it's like
okay well good luck living life with
that logical fallacy as much as you
might believe it to be true but here's a
guy that sold this company for like 50
million dollars getting a half a million
dollar donation right in front of me
telling me do one thing so my thing was
like if I start a business I want to
only do one thing so I have to figure
out what that thing is does that make
sense
so
um I'm talking to my best friend my best
friend skipped two grades of high school
between his parents they have three phds
so in like biochemistry like crazy
intelligent family sister is a doctor
like like my friend is a brilliant guy
and he got a Goldman Sachs internship in
New York as like a second year
university student he's a brilliant guy
I'm not like him
my other best friend I have four best
men at my wedding one has an honors
Physics degree one is the guy I just
told you about one guy now works works
at the World Bank graduated University
with a masters in three years speaks
fluent Chinese
he's from he's a white dude learn
Chinese won a competition got sent to
China for an internship got his master's
degree now works of the World Bank so I
have some pretty smart friends and I'm
really intimidated by them like my
friends I just got lucky are like really
really smart people
and so I'm talking to my best friend I'm
like man I feel I feel very unsecure
because I want to build something I want
to do something
but you're like
skipping two grades of high school how
do I compete with a guy like you because
you know when you're winning you have to
be uncomfortable you have to be winning
against somebody there's a competition
right
and peleg
I'm sure he's listening to this later
he's like
he told me something he's like you know
he's he was a buy side analyst that was
his internship that he was doing
somewhere and he was like meaning that
he would evaluate companies based on how
much they're really worth and so he
would go with these very like you know
um very qualified management teams and
investment teams to go interview you
know like leaders of companies and he
goes there's two kinds of Rich guys that
I've met that's what he told me he goes
the first kind is the one that goes to
an Ivy League school gets into an
investment Bank you know Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan whatever and that guy goes
becomes the managing director but then
you're competing against all the other
guys that went to Ivy League schools he
goes but the most successful people I've
met at Valiant companies is somebody who
is dominating a non-sophisticated
industry but what do you mean he's like
well the richest guy I've interviewed
recently owned the waste removal company
he collects garbage
but his competitors are not Harvard guys
they're unsophisticated so he's like if
you go into an unsophisticated industry
and learn to dominate it you can do
really really well
and so I'm thinking like okay what's a
non-sophisticated industry that has
nothing to do with garbage because I
don't want to pick up garbage
and I see suits I'm thinking okay well
that seems pretty simple who's my
competition that suits
like some guy in a store you know sure
the store might have a nice brand but
it's just like some guy like hello sir I
work in retail I can beat that guy in
sales so it was unsophisticated so that
was my number one thing it had to be
unsophisticated and easy to learn the
reason it had to be easy to learn is
like coming out of the encyclopedia
business I had a lot of friends that I'd
recruited into that business that were
selling books with me so I can recruit
them into suits I also wanted a product
that required no further schooling
because I spent five years in school I
knew that Academia was not for me and I
also wanted a product that gave me uh
because I had delusional aspirations of
being International I don't want to sell
insurance or financial services or real
estate because then I have to be married
to my city I want to be able to travel
the world and build around the world
which actually has come true
so that was my decision it was like
unsophisticated how many cities are you
in oh over 30 something oh wow yeah yeah
so that was a decision
um but
here's something funny so my last name
is tukshar I didn't know this until a
couple of years ago as my dad was
researching some of our family history
tukshar and Yiddish which is like the
language that Jews in the Soviet Empire
spoke means Taylor
like a means clot and share like sheer
or in French that means to cut so my
last name actually means Taylor I had no
idea turns out my great-grandfather had
been like a really really prominent
tailor
pre-World War II Soviet Union and so
maybe there was a little bit of divine
intervention that happened on the back
end that was unintentional but the
things that led to this were just
logical strategic decisions
so
who was your first suit for
uh my first suit was Howard uh he was a
partner at a law firm called gowlings
okay which is what the time was the
largest law firm in Canada I don't know
about now they're gallowing something
now they're they've merged with some
Japanese company and I made a cold call
on the phone
he was if I remember correctly he was a
lawyer that was Aboriginal law in Canada
it's a big thing a lot
I pick up the phone I cold call him
and I'm like hi I'm Dmitry I'm selling
suits blah blah blah and I sound really
good on the phone like at this point
I've been door-to-door so like I I'm not
saying it I say it on the phone I sound
pretty competent even though I'm 25
years old 20s 25 just turned 26 I'm like
I'm pretty competent
and Howard is like you know and he talks
like rich men talk we'll uh you know
slow and deep and thoughtful
so um how much do your suits cost
that's what he asked me now I know that
I've done sales I'm not going to answer
that question I have to because I know
it's a trap and I don't know which way
it's going and I said what do you like
to spend on your suits
now we expect them to say as little as
possible when he goes I would never buy
from a company that sells a suit for
less than three thousand dollars because
that company doesn't know what they're
doing
and I said I'll bring you all the I'll
bring you the nice stuff then that's
what I said I have a video about this so
I shop at his office 27th floor
overlooking uh overlooking uh airport
there's a airport
on the west coast it's like uh like the
seaplanes will land on it like a harbor
you know
uh Vancouver I mean that's just how it
is
so I come in and the first thing Howard
says he's like damn you're young
he just looks and you're young I was I
and I this was before facial hair I'm
like 24 25 you know I can't grow a beard
yet
and I and I'm like okay he's trying to
take power over me I understand what's
happening here and I go Howard let me
ask you a question would you rather buy
a suit from an old incompetent tailor or
a young hungry guy like me
because I'm challenging now I'm like
because I'm I know he sees me and him
you know what I'm saying or he sees
himself in me like he's like oh this
guy's hungry and he's like
okay let's sit down so we sit down and
he buys a suit
he buys the suit how much is the suit it
was it was like 35 3600 kind of like
what he said he would spend right and of
course at the time I'm thinking that's a
lot of money but like I'm just playing
it cool
sign him up and then he's like let me
show you something he's just he sees
that I'm really like I'm like at this
point I am ambitious now I'm like I can
say this is now ambition right like he
shows me how to win he's like you see
that little plane over there that's mine
so he lived in Vancouver Island which is
like Victoria like the naimo like Comox
there's these all these little towns on
the island about two hour Ferry but it's
about a 45 minute flight in so he flew
his own seaplane from the island to work
every morning
and I'm standing there and I never seen
anything like that I'm like I want to
work with people like that for the rest
of my life because that's freaking cool
that's freaking cool that was my first
suit so as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible